[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal live aus
Ankara mit Christian Siebers
guten Abend in allen und merhaba live
hier aus dem Zentrum der türkischen
Hauptstadt an diesem ganz besonderen
Sonntag der Entscheidung über die
Ergebnisse der Wahl in Bremen berichten
wir natürlich auch ausführlich etwas
später in dieser Sendung die Menschen in
der Türkei sind nicht auf den Straßen
aktuell es ist hier deutlich ruhiger als
sonst viele warten offenbar zu Hause ab
angesichts eines
auszählungs-marathons der auf ein enges
Rennen hindeutet aber Spannung und
Anspannung sind hier wirklich überall zu
spüren dieser Wahltag wird die Türkei
verändern das ist klar in welche
Richtung das werden wir in den kommenden
Stunden zeigen
das ist der Präsidenten Palast hier in
Ankara über 1.000 Räume ein gigantischer
Gebäude komplett der zum Symbol wurde
für die Machtfülle in der Hand eines
einzelnen Mannes Präsident recept type
Erdogan sein Herausforderer geh mal
Kilian hat bereits angekündigt er werde
nicht in diesem Palast einziehen wenn er
denn gewählt wird
seit 20 Jahren hat Erdogan das Land
geprägt verändert immer massiver mit
harter Hand gegen alle die er als Gegner
empfindet heute muss er zum ersten Mal
um seine Macht fürchten seit einigen
Stunden wird ausgezählt und das Rennen
um die Macht sieht aktuell so aus um
Präsident zu werden ist eine absolute
Mehrheit von über 50% nötig sonst gibt
es eine Stichwahl Erdogan kommt aktuell
auf 50,43% Herausforderer auf
43,77% der dritte Kandidat ist
chancenlos das sind und das ist das
große ABER aber zahlen die wirklich mit
großer Vorsicht zu behandeln sind dann
ist es lange nicht alles ausgezählt und
die Opposition warnt dass Erdogan Lager
bereits daraus voreilig Schlüssel zu
ziehen
es ist nicht übertrieben zu sagen wir
erleben hier eine Schicksalswahl Anna
heißt
es sieht gut aus für ihren Präsidenten
doch zufrieden sind sie hier vor der AKP
Zentrale in Istanbul noch nicht
unsere Erwartungen lagen höher leider
gibt es viel Missgeburt in unserem Land
die Menschen die rette an den Rücken zu
wenden sind Vaterlandsverräter
[Musik]
die sollen doch das Land verlassen
aber ein bisschen gute Stimmung kann man
sich hier schließlich kaufen was wird
diese Nacht noch bringen eine Frage die
die chp-vorsitzende von Istanbul seit
dem frühen Morgen umtreibt sie glaubt an
ihre Partei das Oppositionsbündnis um
Grillitsch darogulu aber fürchtet die
Wut der Erdogan Anhänger
diejenigen die nicht an die Demokratie
Glauben sind in der Lage alles zu tun um
den Stuhl auf dem sie sitzen zu
zerstören den Tag wird sie deshalb mit
einem Bodyguard verbringen zum ersten
Mal in ihrem Leben denn die
Sicherheitssituation für Abgeordnete der
Opposition sei sehr angespannt so zeigen
Bilder den Oppositionsführer Kemal
College da Rollo auch heute mutmaßlich
in schusssicherer Weste abgeschirmt von
Bodyguards an der Wahlurne in Ankara
unterdessen zeigt sich Erdogan warten
mit Personalausweis und Enkelkind als
vorzeigedemokrat im Wahllokal in
Istanbul zum wahlabschluss ruft Erdogan
über Twitter dazu auf
jetzt ist es wie immer die Zeit die
wahlorden zu schützen schützen sie
weiterhin den Willen unseres Volkes bis
die Ergebnisse feststehen zeitgleich
wahlabschluss in der Stadt Adaman im
Erdbebengebiet hunderttausende haben
nach dem verheerenden Erdbeben die Stadt
verlassen und mussten zur Wahl
zurückkehren dazu zehntausende zur Wahl
registrierte Menschen die beim Beben
verstorben sind Burak bin seit der
Vorsitzende der CHP hier ist
verantwortlich für 1442 Wahlurnen er
hatte große Zweifel ob bei dieser Wahl
alles glatt gehen kann vorerst
erleichterung macht sich breit
es gab keine Probleme an keiner der
Wahlurnen die ich aufsuchte natürlich
hier und da gereizte Stimmung aber es
sind schließlich Wahlen
in der zur Parteizentrale
umfunktionierten Teestube werden nun
auch die Ergebnisse aus den umliegenden
Dörfern gesammelt und ausgewertet die
AKP liegt hier wie überall im Land klar
vorn und nach den Zahlen jetzt bleibt
Erdogan wohl Präsident
die beiden Hauptquartiere der
Kontrahenten hier in Ankara liegen nur
ein paar hundert Meter voneinander
entfernt und wir gehen jetzt live zu
beiden ZDF Türkei Korrespondent Jörg
Brase ist bei Präsident Erdogan und
seine Akten wo sie Hoffnung haben auch
den neuen Präsidenten zu stellen Jörg
wie begründet ist denn das aktuell
mit den Leuten hier redet dann sind die
fest davon überzeugt dass Recep Tayyip
Erdogan ist wieder geschafft hat wir
haben hier mit einigen gesprochen die
fest an den Sieg glauben sie sagen 100
Jahre Republik ist unser und sie rechnen
auch damit dass Erdogan noch heute Nacht
auf den Balkon hier das Hauptquartiers
tritt und zu Ihnen sprechen wird
allerdings muss man sagen dass diese
Zahlen die gemeldet werden relativ sind
der Vorsprung der die staatliche
Nachrichtenagentur meldet der schwindet
mittlerweile auch aber es ist immer noch
ein großer Vorsprung und man hat so ein
bisschen das Gefühl das ist so eine Art
Psycho Krieg ist den wir hier heute
Nacht erleben es gibt Meldungen dass die
abpartei die Meldung von Wahlergebnisse
blockiert dadurch dass sie Einspruch
einlegt die Wahl Behörde die oberste
Wahlbehörde muss diese Einsprüche dann
jeweils prüfen und kann dann erst die
Zahlen zur Zählung zulassen also das
zieht sich hier die Zahlen werden zwar
etwas enger ist wird auch eng der
Abstand wird immer kleiner zwischen den
Kandidaten aber es deutet im Moment
jedenfalls alles darauf hin dass Recep
Erdogan die Nase fahren darf
sehr laut ist es auf jeden Fall man
sieht es auch an den Kopfhörern wir
werden gleich noch mit einer türkischen
Juristin genauer darüber reden erst noch
rüber zu meinem Kollegen Wolf schmiese
er ist beim Herausforderer Kilic tarolo
und der CHP wulfter sieht die Partei die
Party heute Abend doch dünner aus als
erwartet wie sehr steht es noch nach
Machtwechsel aus bei der CRP heute Abend
[Applaus]
also hier rechnet keiner mehr mit einem
Nachtwechsel in dieser Nacht die
Stimmung ist wirklich hier gewichen und
die Hoffnung ist gewichen dass der
Kandidat gewinnen kann und damit die
Demokratie das war sein Schlachtruf wenn
man in die Parteizentrale reingeht dann
sind da die Funktionäre zum
Krisentreffen und die Gesichter sind so
grau wie das Gebäude also dort ist man
der Meinung es ist nicht mit rechten
Dingen zugegangen bei der Auswahl bei
der Auszählen der Stimmen und der
oppositionskandidat hat gerade
getwittert dass er die ganze Nacht nicht
schlafen werde und er bitte die Wahl
Beobachter bitte an den Ohren zu bleiben
und man beruft sich auf die vier großen
Städte wo man doch gewonnen habe und das
können nicht mit rechten Dingen zu gehen
draußen vor der Partei zentrale hört man
hin und wieder Anhänger rufen wir sind
die Soldaten von Mustafa Kemal Atatürk
den Staatsgründer dessen Partei hier im
Hintergrund Ihr Gebäude hat also man ist
offenbar nicht gewillt diesen
Zwischenstand zu akzeptieren
herzlichen Dank an unsere beiden
Reporter heute abend wir nehmen das
Thema auch gleich auf was wir gerade
schon gehört haben die Menschen in der
Türkei nehmen ihr Wahlrecht sehr ernst
ich habe immer wieder gehört in den
letzten Tagen auch von Erdogan Fans sie
erwarten dass der wahre Wille des
türkischen Volks gehört wird gerade vor
dem Hintergrund schlechter Erfahrungen
in der Vergangenheit stellt sich eine
Frage besonders dringend wie korrekt
laufen diese Wahlen ab dazu hat uns ein
Mitglied der europäischen Wahl
Beobachter hier vorhin folgendes gesagt
in der letzten Jahrzehnte hier in der
Türkei hunderte internationale
wahlbeobachtete und tausende
ehrenamtliche waren im ganzen Land
unterwegs haben zigtausende Urnen
bewacht und haben versucht das
bestmöglich zu tun dass diese Wahl so
transparent wie möglich verlaufen ist
wie fair und wie frei sie allerdings
verlaufen ist das werden wir morgen
nachmittag erfahren wenn wir unseren
Bericht vorstellen
auch einiges also aufzuarbeiten dieses
Land und seine wunderbaren Menschen
kämpfen gerade gleich mehrfach was
Inflation anrichtet erleben wir ja auch
in Deutschland hier ist die
Geldentwertung hier in der Türkei ist
die geltentwertung in der Spitze zehnmal
so dramatisch wie bei uns und dann die
Folgen des verheerenden Erdbebens vor
drei Monaten wie wirkt sich diese
gewaltige Erschütterung auf die Wahl aus
um das herauszufinden war ich in der
türkischen Erdbebenregion unterwegs und
habe mit vielen Menschen gesprochen in
einst quirligen Städten die so schlicht
nicht mehr existieren
wie weit weiter angesichts dieser
Zerstörung die Frage stellt sich brutal
jedem der die einst stolze Hauptstraße
von antakyas sieht legendär seit antiken
Zeiten und jetzt
merals hatte hier ein Geschäft jetzt
bleibt ihr nur das Auto Straßenverkauf
sie versucht an die Zukunft zu glauben
und will auch einen politischen
Neuanfang vom Präsidenten ist sie
enttäuscht
kam um uns hier zu helfen wir mussten
vier Tage auf Hilfe warten wenn die
Polizei und die Soldaten früher gekommen
wären wären die Folgen nicht so
furchtbar
über 20.000 tote hier im Zentrum von
Antakya ganze Stadtviertel sind nur noch
Schuttberge und vom Rest dennoch steht
müssen 80% abgetragen werden
[Applaus]
stattdessen überall neue Friedhöfe für
Mütter Väter Kinder alle gestorben am
selben Tag 6 Februar 23
wir treffen hier Menschen die ihre
gesamte Familie verloren haben
das war Gottes Wille sagt er nicht
Schuld der Politik
unser Präsident sorgt die ganze Zeit für
uns daran zweifeln wir nicht möge Gott
dafür sorgen dass er uns erhalten bleibt
Recep taip Erdogan hat die Türkei
umgebaut auch im ganz wörtlichen Sinn
mit Immobilien ließ sich viel Geld
verdienen noch mehr wenn an der
entscheidenden Stelle gespart wird
wir sehen ganze Neubauviertel die dem
Erdbeben kaum etwas entgegenzusetzen
hatten
und direkt daneben deren Bewohner in
Zeltstädten ein Leben mit Schmerz und
Staub die einen verfluchen ihren
Präsidenten die anderen sagen in dieser
Lage kann uns nur einer retten Rezept
fünf bis zehn Jahre wird es dauern bis
hier normales Leben wieder möglich ist
sagen Experten und die sind abseits der
großen Straßen noch gar nicht gewesen
sie hat zwei ihrer Söhne und alle sechs
Enkel begraben müssen und selbst nur
durch ein Wunder überlebt
jetzt ist sie ganz allein
diese Wahl macht für Sie keinen
Unterschied mehr
ich möchte dass Gott mich zu sich holt
sagt sie
was bleibt mir sonst noch
ja die Situation ist wirklich kaum zu
fassen für die Wahl heute mussten
hunderttausende Menschen in ihre
zerstörten Städte und Dörfer
zurückkehren um dort wählen zu können
wir können jetzt live gehen zu meiner
Kollegin Nazan gökte mir sie ist den
Adana im Erdbebengebiet guten Abend NASA
das sind also schwierige Umstände wie
lief denn dieser Wahltag dort ab
ja schönen guten Abend danke Christian
ja für Millionen von Türkinnen und
Türken ist heute wirklich ein Hoch
emotionaler Tag vor allem für die
Bewohner im und aus dem Erdbebengebiet
Hatay du hast es gerade schon gesagt
viele Menschen sind heute zurückgekehrt
in das Erdbebengebiet um ihre Stimme
abzugeben und das haben sie gerne getan
wir konnten Menschen beobachten die in
Schulen in den wenigen Schulen die hier
noch stehen aber auch in Zelten die
extra eingerichtet wurden unter Tränen
ihre Stimme abgegeben haben die haben
mit einem Busunternehmer in Antakya
gesprochen du warst ja für deine
Reportage auch dort der extra für den
heutigen Tag zahlreiche Busse noch mal
neu organisiert hat und die Menschen aus
allen Ecken des Landes hierher gekarrt
hat teilweise auch kostenlos damit die
Menschen hier von ihrem Recht Gebrauch
machen können und ihre Stimme abgeben
können und mit den Menschen mit denen
wir gesprochen haben war der Frust über
das Krisenmanagement des Präsidenten
Erdogan deutlich zu spüren die Menschen
mit denen wir gesprochen haben die
wünschen sich einen Neuanfang einen
politischen Neuanfang für die Region hat
sei aber auch für die ganze Türkei
herzlichen Dank für Deine Eindrücke aus
dem Erdbebengebiet
Professor
ätsche göstete lehrt an der juristischen
Fakultät einer Privatuni hier in Ankara
und ist jetzt live bei uns Frau
Professorin schönen guten Abend guten
Abend wir haben schon gehört es wird
jetzt wahrscheinlich ein juristisches
Ringen um Zahlen um Wahlergebnisse
losgehen wie hat man sich das genau
vorzustellen also es gibt jetzt zwei
Agenturen die die Zahlen durchgeben
einmal die ankeragentur und einmal die
Agentur also die eine ist die
oppositionsnachrichtenagentur und die
andere ist die staatliche auf
erdogan-seite genau und laut Berichten
gibt es ungefähr bei 30.000 Wahlurnen
Ansprüche von Seiten der AKP wurde THP
vorliegt und das bedeutet dass die
Agentur die diese Zahlen die bei den
Wahlen ohne nicht durchgibt die noch
nicht entschieden worden sind von daher
muss man auch jede Zahl mit Genuss
genießen bevor sich genießen weil
einfach die endgültigen Zahlen noch
nicht festlegen also die Zahlen sagen
sie sind durch im Moment eher für
Erdogan aber nicht das tatsächliche
Stimmenverhältnis in der Türkei wieder
wann können wir denn dann tatsächlich
mit einer Auflösung des ganzen rechnen
wer entscheidet denn jetzt am Ende in
diesem Streit also zuerst müssen alle
Einsprüche besichtigt werden und
nachgezählt werden die Stimmen und die
endgültige rechtskräftige Entscheidung
liegt beim hohen Wahlrad beim hohen
Wahlrad wann wird der entscheiden kann
man das schon sagen von der ganz von der
Schnelligkeit des Nachziehens ab es kann
zwei oder bis zu fünf Arbeitstage dauern
also bis der hohe Beirat gesagt hat wir
haben alle Ansprüche angesichtet und
darüber entschieden diese Zahlen sind
die endgültigen Zahlen können wenn nicht
von einer von einem Wahlsieg von einem
der Kandidaten sprechen wie sehr steht
in der hohe wahlart jetzt unter dem
Einfluss des Staatspräsidenten von
receptember also es gibt elf Mitglieder
und beide kommen vom präsentationshof
vom vom Staatsrat aber das sind
natürlich hohe Richter aber man darf das
auch mit Vorsicht genießen denn auch die
hohen werden mittelbar und oder
unmittelbar vom Staatspräsidenten
benannt oder vom Staatspräsidenten
benannten Rat des der Richter und
Staatsanwälte also da könnte uns ein
längeres Tauziehen tatsächlich
bevorstehen jetzt hier wie wir es ja
häufiger sehen mittlerweile bei
verschiedenen Wahlen in verschiedenen
Gegenden dieser Welt es gab ja heute
auch eine Parlamentswahl in der Türkei
ist denn da schneller mit einem Ergebnis
zu rechnen auf dass ich dann tatsächlich
auch alle einigen laut Gerichten ja also
den die Einsprüche richten sich eher an
die Präsidentschaftswahl aber nicht
gegen die Parlamentswahl und diese
Zahlen könnten wir dann vielleicht schon
in zwei Arbeitstagen auf dem Tisch
liegen haben okay Frau Professorin
herzlichen Dank dass Sie heute Abend bei
uns waren hier live aus dem Stadtzentrum
von Ankara sehr interessante Analyse
also doch noch einige Zeit dauern die
Nerven hier liegen blank das haben wir
glaube ich auch schon zeigen können wird
heute Nacht die Demokratie siegen oder
könnte das wie manche meinen erstmal die
letzten echten Wahlen in der Türkei
gewesen sein
es gibt politische Gegner von Erdogan
die das Ergebnis dieser Nacht bei denen
das Ergebnis dieser Nacht darüber
entscheidet ob sie frei kommen oder den
Rest ihres Lebens im Gefängnis
verbringen müssen das ist auf jeden Fall
eine Zäsur für die Türkei mit Folgen
auch für Deutschland wir werden weiter
berichten auch morgen hier live aus
Ankara aber jetzt erstmal zur anderen
wichtigen Wahl heute und die hat eine im
Blick guten Abend
vielen Dank Christian für diese
Eindrücke aus Ankara und bis morgen
und wir schauen also nach Bremen wo die
Bremische Bürgerschaft der Landtag neu
bestimmt wird in Bremen und Bremerhaven
regiert seit 77 Jahren die SPD man
glaubt das kaum bei der letzten Wahl
2019 kassierten die Sozialdemokraten
allerdings ein fetten Dämpfer weil die
CDU sie überholte trotzdem blieb die SPD
an der Macht nun in einer Koalition mit
Grünen und Linkspartei ob diese
Koalition weiter regieren kann ist eine
der Fragen die Antworten hat Matthias
vorne auf in unserem Wahlstudio in
Bremen Matthias was sagen uns die
neuesten Zahlen
zunächst mal ist das schöne ist genug
ausgezählt ist wir haben die erste
Hochrechnung die Hochrechnung des
Landeswahlleiters und die Zahlen schauen
wir uns jetzt an demnach kommt die CDU
auf 25,6 Prozent mit Verlusten die SPD
kommt auf 29,2% ist damit widerstärkste
Partei die Grünen 12,0 mit deutlichen
Verlusten die Linke 12,1 und die FDP bei
5,2 das ist noch nicht sicher ob sie in
Bremen und Bremerhaven die 5% Hürde
tatsächlich schafft und die Bürger in
Wut eine rechtsaußenpartei kommt auf 9,3
% in Abwesenheit der AFD die wegen
Formfehlern hier nicht antreten dürfte
und jetzt schauen wir mal was das hieße
an regierungsoptionen hier in Bremen
hier sehen wir das Bündnis das bisher an
regiert hat SPD Grüne und Linke man
braucht für die absolute Mehrheit 44
Sitze die kennen locker drüber mit 50
sitzen die große Koalition in Bremen
tatsächlich noch so heißen könnte SPD
und CDU haben sogar auf 51 Sitze das
ginge also erst recht SPD Grüne und FDP
das ist politisch etwas was schwer
vorstellbar ist und die FDP wackelt und
es würde auch nicht reichen 43 Sitze das
ist der aktuelle Stand und die
Datenbasis für alles weitere vielen Dank
Matthias nach Bremen in unserer
wahlstudium Bremen ist in vielerlei
Hinsicht ein besonderes Pflaster die
rot-grün-rote Koalition regiert regiert
hier in Bremen weitgehend geräuschlos
erst in den letzten Wochen im Wahlkampf
gegen SPD Bürgermeister bovenschulte
vorsichtshalber zu den Grünen auf
Distanz um nicht in den Berliner
Abwärtstrend um Heizungstausch und
Vetternwirtschaft hineingezogen zu
werden schrille politische Töne
lautstarken Parteienstreit gab es in
Bremer Wahlkampf nicht keine Klage über
die Kandidaten und den Tag in Bremen
er löste SPD-Anhänger nach einem langen
und intensiven Wahlkampf andreas
bovenschulter hat die SPD wieder auf
Platz eins in der Wählergunst geführt
und damit das Selbstverständnis der
Bremer Sozialdemokraten als rote Bastion
wieder hergestellt
genossen und genossen was für ein Tag
was für ein Ergebnis wir haben einen
harten Wahlkampf gemeinsam gefochten und
es hat sich gelohnt die SPD in Bremen
zurück die Nummer eins in Bremen das
sind wir
[Musik]
dennoch losgelöst und zufrieden
Herausforderer Frank immer von der CDU
er hat in den Feldern Bildung innere
Sicherheit und Verkehr erfolgreich
attackiert aber am Ende konnte der
Oppositionschef an der Popularität des
Bürgermeisters nicht vorbei die mir am
Wahlabend noch ein Gesprächsangebot
macht
Thomas
eine Koalition zusammenzuführen aber er
weiter so will mit diesen rot rot grün
mit der ideologischen Politik auch von
den Grünen oder aber dafür stehen will
dass wir uns endlich mal und die Alltag
sorgen dieser Stadt dieser Menschen
dieser Stadt auch kümmern wir stehen zu
Koalitionsverhandlungen bereit trösten
Umarmungen brauchte Spitzenkandidatin
Maike Schäfer von den Grünen ihre Partei
erleidet offenbar Verluste von um die
sechs Prozent die grüne Verkehrspolitik
in Bremen eine der Ursachen für die
Verluste die grüne Spitzenkandidatin sah
allerdings auch weitere
wir haben uns sicherlich alle viel mehr
gewünscht und das Kopf am Kopf Rennen
zwischen Frank Imhoff und Andreas
bovenschultert das hat uns eher
geschadet es ist auch sicherlich so
gewesen dass uns der fehlende Rückenwind
aus Berlin nicht geholfen hat bei dieser
Wahl die Linke hat im Großen und Ganzen
das Ergebnis von der letzten Wahl
bestätigt und sieht eine solide Basis
für die Fortsetzung von rot grün rot und
so wie sie jetzt aussieht wenn die
Prognosen nachher auch reale Ergebnisse
werden würde ich mich freuen weil alles
dafür spricht dass wir diese
Regierungsarbeit fortsetzen können
die FDP muss um den Wiedereinzug in die
Bürgerschaft Bank ist aber eher drin als
draußen
die Wählervereinigung BÜRGER IN WUT
konnte fast ein zweistelliges Ergebnis
einfahren und hat offenbar deutlich
davon profitiert dass die AFD zur Wahl
nicht zugelassen wurde
und zugeschaltet ist uns jetzt aus
Bremen der Bürgermeister der Stadt und
SPD-Spitzenkandidat dessen Partei dieses
Mal immerhin drei Prozent deutlich vor
der cdulich guten Abend Herr
bovenschulte moin die SPD also wieder an
erster Stelle mit knapp 30 Prozent 29.2
in der letzten Hochrechnung das ist aber
immer noch ehrlich gesagt das
zweitschlechteste Ergebnis ihrer Partei
in Bremen wie zufrieden sind Sie damit
ich bin sehr zufrieden dass es unter
schwierigen Umständen ein grandioses
Ergebnis aber sie haben Recht da ist
noch Luft nach oben wenn wir jetzt vier
Jahre weiterhin gute Politik machen dann
kann in vier Jahren das noch ausgebaut
werden
sie können sich vermutlich aussuchen ob
sie jetzt mit rot grün rot weitermachen
wollen oder mit der CDU Herr Imhoff hat
ihn ja gerade schon ein Angebot gemacht
ob sie mit der CDU weiter reagieren
wollen wächst ihre Sympathie für die
groko gerade angesichts der schlechten
Ergebnisses für die Grünen
also erstmal habe ich immer gesagt auch
vor der Wahl die jetzige Regierung
hatten gute Arbeit gemacht hat das Land
Bremen solide und unaufgeregt durch die
verschiedenen Krisen der letzten Jahre
gesteuert und es ist aber auch so dass
wir ohne feste Koalitionsaussage in den
Wahlkampf gezogen sind das gilt jetzt
natürlich auch nach der Wahl weil wir
gesagt haben wir müssen gucken anhand
der konkreten Inhalte welche Koalition
am besten geeignet ist die
Zukunftsfragen Bremens zu lösen
Wirtschaft und Arbeit sozialer
Zusammenhalt Sicherheit und Ordnung und
da werden wir jetzt gucken wie die und
was die Gespräche ergeben die wir mit
allen demokratischen Parteien führen und
auf dieser Grundlage kann dann seriös
entschieden werden die Bürger in Wut die
anstelle der AFD ja angetreten sind
haben in Bremen jede zehnte Stimme
bekommen in Bremerhaven sogar jede
fünfte 20 Prozent wie wollen Sie diese
unzufriedenen Protest Wähler überzeugen
und wieder in das Parteien System
zurückholen
ich glaube die richtige Strategie ist
deutlich zu machen dass wir ein
Gemeinwesen sind wo alle Menschen ihren
Platz haben wo sich niemand ausgegrenzt
fühlen muss und wo auch niemand
ausgegrenzt wird und das bedeutet
natürlich soziale Sicherheit das
bedeutet auch in anderen Lebensbereichen
Sicherheit weil ich glaube das ist das
was die Menschen sich bei allen
Umbrüchen wünschen die wissen es müssen
sich Dinge verändern die wissen dass wir
mehr Klimaschutz brauchen dass wir mehr
Digitalisierung brauchen aber dabei muss
die Gesellschaft immer alle Menschen
mitnehmen und dieses Gefühl
existenzieller Sicherheit das ist das
entscheidende ist auch der Kern
sozialdemokratischer Politik und das
werden wir in den nächsten vier Jahren
vorantreiben und eine grundlage dafür
ist eine starke Wirtschaft und ist eine
Gesellschaft in der jeder auch die
Möglichkeit hat sein Lebensunterhalt
durch eigene Arbeit zu verdienen
andreas bovenschulte war das von der SPD
der alte und wie es aussieht auch neue
Bürgermeister von Bremen vielen Dank für
das Gespräch
herzlichen Dank
und wir machen weiter mit den
Nachrichten und die hat Hanna Zimmermann
für sie obwohl der 50-stündige
Bahnstreik der Gewerkschaft EVG gestern
abgewendet werden konnte werden morgen
zahlreiche Züge ausfallen lauter
Deutschen Bahn ist ein Drittel der
Fernverkehrsverbindungen betroffen und
auch im Regionalverkehr wird es
Einschränkungen geben grund sei die
kurze Reaktionszeit in der der
Bahnbetrieb wieder hochgefahren werden
musste für Passagiere hat die Bahn aus
diesem Grund die Zugbindung für Fahrten
bis Dienstag aufgehoben
Israel ist keine 24 Stunden nach der
beschlossenen Waffenruhe von einer
Rakete aus dem Gazastreifen angegriffen
worden und beschoss daraufhin eine
Stellung militanter Palästinenser die
Feuerpause war zuvor im Gazastreifen
gefeiert worden Israel öffnete
seinerseits zwei Grenzübergänge zu dem
Küstengebiet seit Dienstag hatten sich
die israelische Armee und der islamische
die hat immer wieder mit Raketen
angegriffen dutzende Menschen kamen ums
Leben
erstmals seit dem Militärputsch 2014
könnte es in Thailand zu einem
Machtwechsel kommen vorläufigen
Ergebnissen zur Folge liegen bei der
heutigen Parlamentswahl die zwei
wichtigsten Oppositionsparteien klar
vorne weil das Militär allerdings bei
der Wahl des Regierungschefs
mitbestimmen kann könnte der amtierende
Ministerpräsident trotz möglicher
Niederlage an der Macht bleiben klar ist
welche Koalition regieren kann kann es
Wochen
der Zyklon Mocca hat mit rund 200
Kilometern pro Stunde die Küste von
Myanmar und Bangladesch erreicht
Medienberichten zufolge kamen mindestens
drei Menschen ums Leben Mokka ist laut
Meteorologen der schwerste Sturm in der
Region seit mehr als 15 Jahren das
genaue Ausmaß der Schäden ist noch nicht
klar in den vergangenen Tagen waren
Küstenregionen in Myanmar und
Bangladesch mit hunderttausenden
Menschen evakuiert worden
mehr Sympathiebekundung geht nicht Olaf
und Woody mir duzen sich jetzt das
Kanzleramt schickte eigens einen
Regierungsflugzeug nach Rom um den
ukrainischen Präsidenten gestern Nacht
nach Berlin zu holen und selenski
bedankte sich beim Bundespräsidenten
beim Bundeskanzler und dem deutschen
Volk für die fantastische Solidarität
mit der Ukraine wenn man genau hinhört
dann ist zwar die deutsche ukrainische
Verstimmung vorbei
Meinungsunterschiede aber bleiben bei
der Lieferung von Kampfjets z.B oder die
möglichst raschen ukrainischen nato-
als kurz nach zehn aus dem Herrn
Präsident und dem Herrn Bundeskanzler
schon wo Lotti mir und Olaf geworden
sind zeigt Scholz auf den ehemaligen
Todesstreifen vor der Terrasse seines
Büros
hier war nichts sagt Scholz und gibt
selenski und seinem zerstörten besetzten
Land ein Versprechen
wir unterstützen euch so lange wie es
nötig sein wird Scholz und selensky das
ist eine lange gewundene Geschichte die
heute eine überraschende Wendung nimmt
überraschend vor allem für Scholz noch
in der Nacht hatte die Flugbereitschaft
der Bundesregierung selenski aus Rom
abgeholt begleitet von 2 € Fightern und
in ein hermetisch abgeriegeltes
Regierungsviertel gebracht
selensky beginnt beim Bundespräsidenten
auch eine lange Geschichte der Gast duzt
oder dankt Steinmeier nicht zumindest
nicht öffentlich er schreibt danke
Deutschland ins Goldene Buch auch über
Scholz hat selensky noch vor drei
Monaten geklagt ich muss Druck machen
der Ukraine zu helfen und ihn ständig
überzeugen davon heute kein Wort mehr
nur Lob und Applaus für das gestern
verkündete neue Milliarden paket reicht
Deutschlands Hilfe jetzt aus wird sie
einen Unterschied machen für den
Gegenangriff
noch einige Besucher und dann ist es
ausreichend
viel Erfolg
das selenski zusagt keine Gebiete in
Russland anzugreifen sorgt bei den
Deutschen für Erleichterung dass der
Ukrainer um Kampfjets bittet überrascht
Scholz nicht aber er überhört es es
folgt ein weiteres ausnahmebild an
diesem Ausnahmetag Scholz und selensky
legen fast alle Strecken in Berlin mit
dem Hubschrauber zurück nie dagewesene
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen nachdem aus der
Berliner Polizei Besuchs Details
herausgesickert waren dann Aachen das
ukrainische Volk und der ukrainische
Präsident nehmen den Karlspreis in
Empfang und jeder sieht das bedeutet
etwas aber selensky will diesen Moment
teilen und lobt ausgerechnet Olaf Scholz
wie der noch nie gelobt worden ist
als du lieber Olaf
die zeitenwände gesehen hast hast du
angefangen so zu handeln wie der
Verteidiger
Europas handeln soll Europa wird dir
immer dankbar sein und dieser Regierung
Deutschlands
das war selenskys diplomatische
Offensive vor der Frühjahrsoffensive die
Ukraine weiß Tadel verpflichtet aber Lob
verpflichtet noch mehr
die Ergebnisse der Wahlen in Bremen und
in der Türkei werden uns sicher in der
nächsten Woche noch beschäftigen dazu
kommen aber auch noch diese Themen der
heute journal Ausblick von Björn Weidner
[Musik]
am Dienstag soll im Prozess um den Raub
aus dem Grünen Gewölbe in Dresden ein
Urteil gesprochen werden Schmuck im Wert
von über 100 Millionen Euro nahmen
Mitglieder eines Berliner Clans mit die
sechs Angeklagten haben zum Teil
umstrittene Deals abgeschlossen
Geständnisse für mildere Strafen
ebenfalls am Dienstag werden in kann die
Filmfestspiele eröffnet und die Liste
der angekündigten Stars ist lang auch
deutsche werden im Wettbewerb um die
Goldene Palme antreten Regisseur
bimbender sogar gleich mit zwei Filmen
Gipfel des Europarats sind äußerst
selten zuletzt darf man sich 2005 Männer
Mittwoch die Staats- und Regierungschefs
der 46 Mitgliedsländer in Reykjavik
zusammenkommen soll das Ukraine
schadensregister ins Leben gerufen
werden die Dokumentation der
Kriegsschäden soll künftigen
Gerichtsverfahren als Grundlage dienen
am Freitag beginnt in Hiroshima der G7
Gipfel nukleare Abrüstung und
Ernährungssicherheit werden Themen sein
aber auch Maßnahmen wie die
Weltwirtschaft vor Krisen geschützt
werden kann sei es durch den russischen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine oder einer
möglichen Eskalation in China Taiwan
Konflikt
und so wird das Wetter in den kommenden
Tagen morgen scheint am Vormittag im
Norden noch häufig die Sonne später
kommen hier aber Schauer und Gewitter
auf im Süden überwiegen die Wolken und
es muss den ganzen Tag mit Regen
gerechnet werden die Temperaturen
steigen auf 14 bis 22 Grad am Dienstag
und Mittwoch gibt es vor allem ganz im
Süden Regen sonst wird es zunehmend
freundlicher die Temperaturen liegen bei
8 bis 19 Grad und hier geht es jetzt
weiter mit dem Krimi Mord im Mittsommer
und Morgen begrüßen Sie hier Gundula
Gause und Sonja Hayali die nächsten
heute Nachrichten gibt es an diesem
spannenden Wahlabend gegen 0:35 Uhr mit
Christopher Wehrmann Ihnen noch einen
schönen Abend tschüss tschüss
[Musik]